i'm cat tim i'm bill hemmer i'm harris
faulkner and this
is the fox news rundown
friday june 25th 2021 i'm jessica
rosenthal
the debate about race and policing
reignited after the murder of george
floyd
and the officer convicted of killing him
will be sentenced today
police and race so entwined that you
can't separate the two
we speak with former nypd police
commissioner bill bratton
i'm chris foster a supreme court ruling
and new state laws have college athletes
closer to getting paid
the college model as we know and have
lived and seen it
over basically all of our lives is
in severe severe straits in terms of
being able to continue going forward
clay travis is a fox news sports
contributor
and i'm joe koncha i've got the final
word on the fox news rundown
[Music]
two months ago former minneapolis police
officer derek chovin was convicted of
murdering george floyd we the jury in
the above entitled matter has to count
one
unintentional second-degree murder while
committing a felony find the defendant
guilty
he was also convicted of third degree
murder and second degree manslaughter
and today chauvin is scheduled to be
sentenced
second-degree murder alone can result in
up to 40 years in prison
after the verdict floyd's family and
supporters spoke out in relief
but minnesota attorney general keith
ellison said at the time that it should
mark a beginning of sorts
this verdict reminds us that we must
make enduring
systemic societal change more than a
month ago
the minnesota public safety commissioner
john harrington and i
released the recommendations of our
working group on reducing deadly force
encounters with law enforcement
what all of us in that working group
including law enforcement
wanted is for everyone to go home safe
we need to use this verdict as an
inflection point
after floyd's murder protests began
around the country soon after there was
talk of national police reform
even defunding police departments since
then crime has risen further especially
violent crime
and the debate continues to shift about
the kinds of police reforms that are
needed
and what city and state governments
should be spending money on as the
defund police crowd demands that more be
spent on social programs
my experience goes over 50-year period
came into policing in 1970 at a time of
also great societal change civil rights
movement
anti-war movement bill bratton is the
former police chief of new york
los angeles and boston's police
departments and
today in 2021 we are now in another
i would describe is revolutionary period
uh and it's an exciting time in many
respects but it's also a challenging
time
challenging with rising crime rates and
concerning fear crime
racial tension exciting in that
out of this crisis comes the opportunity
to maybe uh make significant advances
in one uh dealing more effectively with
crime disorder
and two at the same time improving the
uh race relations in this country that
have been so
problematic over so many centuries now
as people talk about
you know police reform race defunding
police or
refunding them now what would you say is
the reason
we we got here to this moment and how
did the issues surrounding policing
really explode after george floyd in an
even bigger way than after
you know michael brown and ferguson or
eric garner or freddie gray and others i
think i'm asking you to give us a little
bit of a history lesson and take you
back in time here to the maybe the 80s
and 90s
well that history lesson is something i
spent a lot of time on in the book the
profession
it's a memoir it's a tutorial
but it's also the history of policing to
my experiences over those 50 years
and we are constantly reforming
constantly changing
but some of the constants are the issue
of race and racial tensions in this
country
issues around police and how police
perform and behave
and the reality is police and race are
so entwined that you can't separate the
two
you're not going to resolve a lot of the
racial tension in this country
a lot of the concerns about police
performance behavior effectiveness
without addressing both of them at the
same time and that's certainly what
we're in the midst of at the moment
an extraordinary crises of confidence in
police
to effectively deal with issues of race
and with our country's minority
population particularly our black
population
so the tensions that exploded around
george floyd i think took us all by
surprise
because for a number of years we've been
dealing with the ferguson effects
so-called ferguson effect
and we thought we were resolving
some of those issues but quite clearly
the murder of george floyd by derek
children
nobody expected that explosion and what
was different this time was it wasn't
just the black
community uh coming out to demonstrate
and uh expressed concern it was joined
by a phenomenal amount
across section of america whites and
others uh different age groups
and uh estimated 20 25 million people
participate in those demonstrations
so quite clearly a nerve had been
touched with this murder
and out of crises comes opportunity and
that was reflected in the president's
uh remarks where he intends to spend
billions of dollars
on a broad-based set of strategies to
address
what he believes are all the issues that
have been exposed by the
uh attention around george floyd's verb
so let's hope that's the case as we go
forward that uh
we continue this act of reform that
we're not much of our history
i do want to ask you about president
biden's um
reform plans but i want to ask you first
how how do we transition now you said
that these issues of race and policing
are entwined
they cannot be separated and i want to
follow up on that because one of my
questions is
it seems like there can be no more room
for
error bad judgment whatever you want to
call it
someone of color who turned out to be
unarmed
but maybe was running and reaching for a
cell phone simply cannot be shot and
killed by police again
um i feel like if there's another
incident
it will just it will just continue this
this argument will just continue this
debate and this this festering issue
i'm just wondering is that is it
possible like can
can any kind of police reform achieve
that
no that's the sad reality you will
always have incidents
of unarmed people killed by the police
blacks or otherwise
uh the good news is is that the number
of incidents has been
in decline washington post probably has
the most
accurate uh accounting of that going
back to 2015.
in an average year about a thousand
people are killed by police
in about 3 000 incidents involving
uh police engaging in gun battles or in
some instances
using force against an unarmed person
whether that
person not out with a gun but uh without
some other weapon on
indication george 40 no women at all so
good news is those numbers have been
declining uh bad news is
you're always going to have incidents
like this but
what you try to do is learn from each
one we've learned a lot from the george
floyd incident and that's bringing about
phenomenal
thinking and initiatives to uh
try to reduce the times that police have
to deal with the mentally ill
the drug addicted uh or the
others who are in emotional distress and
so there's gonna be a lot of experiments
going on around the country that
hopefully reduce even further these
incidents
well if there is an experiment that does
work i hope you weigh in on it
um and tell us about it that you find
that it works or you think it works
um let's go back to president biden this
week he
um he addressed the rise in violent
crime that we are seeing
and he said he's been doing this for a
long time
and we know what works and then he
followed that up by saying
you have to address background checks
make them more stringent and go after
rogue gun dealers
assault weapons bans are good in his
mind um and he used the term assault
weapons
and backing community policing and
social programs
uh those were the three that he listed
is is that wrong is it missing something
or is it on target as far as you're
concerned
no the of the three you identified and
those are three elements of a much
larger package you talked about
the gun licensing issues
i think there's a lot of support among
the public for that
unfortunately there's not political
support uh i don't think you're going to
see much progress on that one
unfortunately
on the issue of assault weapons man uh
he's going back to the 1994 crime bill
that he helped to inaugurate
where he had the 10-year ban i had some
good effects i don't see
that moving forward either at this time
it didn't move forward after a lot about
mass murders
so i don't see it moving forward at this
time again fact is we have 30 to 40
million of those weapons
already in the hands of american
citizens
and they also constitute a relatively
small amount of
the shootings we're talking about the
third one i think is the most important
that's this idea of
understanding that community policing
works and its many elements
and he seems to be potentially putting a
lot of resources
money into that one more cops over time
more research more community-based
efforts to deal with the emotionally ill
as well addicted etc
so i was impressed with his plan if it
was laid out in terms of its
comprehensiveness
it was on something obviously done
overnight uh
gun issues uh i'm encouraged by some of
the enforcement activity he wants to
take these five task forces
going into five cities have some of the
most violent gang-related gun crime
the strengthening of the atf that
has been weakened dramatically over the
last 30 years
uh if you get that entity that agency
strengthened once again that'll be a
phenomenal resource
to help local police so a lot of good
stuff in that bill the devil is always
in the details and
fortunately a lot of it does not
necessarily require congressional
approval as best i can tell
finally i want to go back to what we
were speaking about earlier and that is
that
race and policing are sort of
intertwined
there's the perception among some that
there's just a few bad apples
among police and then there's this
perception among others that there's
something inherently racist about police
work
um republican senator tim scott even
said he'd been pulled over a number of
times
as a senator um some in the in the bad
apple camp
say this is about statistics that it
comes down to who's committing more
of a given city's crime and and that's
that's the population that police are
tasked with going after
i'm wondering where do you where do you
fall on this
well this issue is like a rubik's cube
that you've identified several of those
squares on that jew some of the
different arguments
is there systemic racism in some
departments there is
is it existing in the profession as a
whole no
i don't believe so are there some cops
who engage in systemic uh
spacious policing practices certainly uh
there's no denying that
uh proving that is very difficult but
the issue
is that there is no denying the tension
between
race and policing and it's compounded by
the problem of the high rates of crime
unfortunately
in poor neighborhoods many of which are
minority neighborhoods and many of which
are black neighborhoods
that bring a lot of police into those
neighborhoods to deal with those
shootings and murders
something that's not even being looked
at closely is the significant increase
in police officers being killed in the
line of duty
so went up last year it's now up
dramatically again this year
so there's so many elements to this
issue
that the good news is that we've become
much more adept at discussing it
we've become much more uh able to look
at these things uh with the videos that
are available
and uh there's a lot of desire
to change it right now the most i've
ever seen over 50 years have been the
business
and before you can solve a problem you
have to admit you have a problem
so no matter what your perspective is
about this issue i think we are
all on common ground it is a problem and
whatever this cause is
it needs to be addressed and fortunately
this tends to be a lot of willingness to
address it at this time
former chief bill bratton author of the
new book the profession thank you so
much for your time
i should be with you all with us thank
you
this is joe koncha with your fox news
commentary coming up
it's not getting paid to play but
starting next thursday july 1st
college athletes in six states will by
law be allowed to make money off their
name image and likeness with things like
endorsements and appearance fees
the ncaa's board of directors has been
meeting to figure out its own plan
for now just allowing student athletes
in those states to take advantage of the
law with schools in other states allowed
to make their own policies
this is after the supreme court ruled
unanimously monday that college
basketball and football players can
receive
education-based financial benefits over
the current cap set by the ncaa
i think it's fairly substantial uh
returning goals
opinion that was written by justice
gorsuch dealing with antitrust
violations in the way that college
athletes are compensated
clay travis is a fox news sports
contributor it is much less expansive
than basically the road map that was
provided by
brett kavanaugh in terms of the overall
anti-trust
issues and to read his opinion which is
a concurring opinion
uh it suggests basically that the
college model
as we know and have lived and seen it
over
basically all of our lives is uh in
severe
uh severe straights in terms of being
able to continue going forward
yeah i mean part of the ncaa argument
and just how like you said how we
thought of college sports is this
sort of amateur purity i guess and
justice kavanaugh wrote
uh traditions alone cannot justify the
ncaa's decision to build a massive money
raising enterprise on the backs of
student athletes who aren't fairly
compensated nowhere else in america can
businesses get away with agreeing
not to pay their workers a fair market
rate on the theory that their product
isn't defined by not paying their
workers a fair market rate so
in other words the ncaa is making money
by
espousing these ideals that they're not
paying the kids
yeah and of course the complicating
factor here is there's a big difference
between
say the starting quarterback for the
university of alabama and
a women's field hockey player and the
the argument i think that the ncaa would
make if they were able to make a strong
argument here
is really the the divergent paths there
you have revenue producing and
non-revenue producing sports football
and men's basketball makes money every
other sport at college
loses money and departments would argue
that they take the money
from the profitable teams and they roll
that into scholarships and support for
the teams that are not profitable
so really what you have is a dichotomy
here between the revenue producing
aka the profitable teams which are a
small minority of them
and uh the non-revenue producing losing
dollar teams which are the vast majority
and how are you going to reconcile those
and then it gets more complicated this
is me putting my lawyer hat on
would you consider title ix name image
and likeness
and all the other complexities that are
going to be rolled
into uh attacking the existing
collegiate model
yeah this native image and likeness
thing uh six states now
have laws kicking in july 1st that the
college athletes can be paid for their
name image and likeness stuff like
if you want to do a commercial uh
license your name to a video game
and i guess it's sort of a split the
baby thing where okay the kids are now
allowed to go out and make that money
but the schools aren't directly paying
them
yeah and it'll get complicated right
because you could imagine where
a school has let's say a shoe contract
or an apparel contract and then an
individual player
wants to have a different contract you
can also imagine
what are going to be permissible name
image and likeness endorsement
opportunities i don't think for instance
gambling companies alcohol
uh or for for lack of a better way strip
clubs right i mean
i don't think the college athletes would
be able to endorse those products and be
associated with the university
so figuring out what is it is not
appropriate how the money is going to be
distributed who makes those decisions
i mean this is just a massive
undertaking that i think it'll take the
better part of a decade to actually
resolve
yeah uh and those endorsement deals for
example could be a way
to get around the idea of like of
literal bidding wards for recruits
yes what if alabama comes in and says
okay we have a place a deal in place for
sponsors
play here and we'll guarantee you x
dollars in endorsement income
if you just go to these you know car
dealership openings for example
yeah no doubt and also remember inside
of the teams themselves there's
relatively few athletes who have a
really substantial example to you
uh value so use your example alabama's
got
a starting quarterback or starting
running back or whoever it might be
has infinitely more value than an
offensive alignment point
and so within the teams themselves you
would create
a real divergence in terms of guys that
are able to have
substantial value and name image and
likeness uh something as simple as how
many people would show up
over the years to get let's say tim
tebow's autograph
uh when he played at the university of
florida compared to the vast majority of
university of florida uh
teammates that tend to go might have or
there would be no money
so does that money get distributed
evenly across the entire team
uh what exactly is the mechanism by
which this is going to occur
i think it's pretty fascinating yeah and
now that you mentioned it what happens
if
that starting quarterback is suddenly
pulling in
six seven figures for endorsement deals
and that offensive lineman who's
protecting him is getting buckets how
does that affect team dynamics
no doubt which is why i think some
people will argue that
what needs to happen and i think this
will be an interesting uh
debate is does for instance all of the
name image and likeness money
roll into a overall fund that is
distributed mostly
to all of the different athletes and how
title i'm going to play in here right
because
male athletes are much more valuable in
name image and likeness than female
athletes because
football and men's basketball are the
the lion's share of
where viewership comes from so under
title ix
you have to have an equal amount of
scholarship athletes for both men and
women
how would the funds be distributed would
we require
that a quarterback be compensated the
same as a diver
those are really interesting questions
that again i think much of the court
will have to be
uh figuring out yeah i mean or even a
women's golfer i mean there's there is
no
yes there is no women's football team so
it's not like you can just put it up
among the men and women's basketball
programs
um well we'll see how that goes over the
next few years it looks like the
writing's on the wall even if the
writing is kind of messy
clay another big sports story this week
has been las vegas raiders defensive end
carl nasib coming out as gay
the first publicly gay active nfl player
ever now to me part of the story
though is how not big it sort of was it
was kind of noted everybody said okay
carl thanks got it and everybody's just
moved on
well i think that's because we went
through this with michael sam which
arguably was a much
bigger story for people who have
forgotten michael sam was a missouri
defensive end
who announced that he was gay and then
uh
before you announced it before the nfl
draft so you had this huge run-up of a
multi-day story
surrounding would he get drafted what
was the impact going to be of having an
openly gay player
in an nfl locker room and then he didn't
make the active roster now he played in
preseason games
all of those things took place in more
massive stories
but in general i think probably
the reason there's been a relatively
muted reaction is one
this player is not particularly well
known but two uh within the last decade
we went through michael sam being
covered uh
as a uh as a major story in the world
of uh of the nfl and so i think a lot of
people are over this i think also in a
positive way
and a negative way all people care about
with the nfl is
whether or not you could perform on the
field so whether you're the nfl man of
the year
or whether you are a guy who's got off
field issues with getting arrested for
instance
most of the time both nfl teams players
and
fans all that matters is your production
and the uh
individual off the field for better or
worse when it comes to pretty much
anything
doesn't really matter it's all about
your production and certainly
even fantasy football has made that even
more paramount i think in the world of
sports fans care about rushing yards
passing yards touchdowns sacks a number
of points allowed
but they don't really care very much
about any of the larger context of
athletes i think particularly the nfl
clay finally do you have any thoughts
about this sticky stuff crackdown major
league baseball pitchers have always
cheated they've always tried to get a
better grip on the ball
but the last few years pitchers care
about what's called spin rate the faster
the ball spins the harder it is to hit
and if you can get a you know more
tactile
grip on the ball it'll come off your
fingers faster and now major league
baseball with offense down
is saying okay we can't have this
anymore i think the techs
look bad um in terms of the way that the
game's being stopped certainly we had a
max surgery for the washington nationals
those are already managing i believe the
philly's a big confrontation there gets
a lot of attention
i know that rob manfred the major league
baseball commissioner will say that he
thinks it's working well
i think most fans would disagree with
that the way that it's being implemented
right now with
checks going on during the course of
games i think for most
fans does not make the game look better
clay travis founder of outkick also a
fox news sports contributor you can hear
him daily on the radio
the clay and bucks show clay travis
thanks for coming on the fox news
rundown
hey i appreciate you all having me
[Music]
thanks
jason in the house the jason chaffetz
podcast dive deeper than the headlines
in the party lines
as i take on american life politics and
entertainment
subscribe now on foxnewspodcast.com
or wherever you download podcasts
and now some good news with tanya j
powers
i don't know about you but i've got a
lot of questions when it comes to space
travel and one of them was answered this
week
how do astronauts do laundry in space
well it turns out they don't the
associated press reports that the
astronauts wear their
undies their gym clothes and everything
else until they
just can't stand themselves any longer
than they throw the clothes away
and am i the only one with a mental
picture of somebody's worn out t-shirt
floating through space
well nasa says it's doing something
about the dirty laundry situation
it is teaming up with proctor and gamble
to figure out how to clean astronauts
clothes
in space so they could be reused just
like we do here on earth
this week procter gamble announced it
will send a pair of tide detergent and
stain removal experiments to the space
station later this year
and next year all part of the galactic
battle against
soiled and sweaty clothes rocket cargo
space is tight
and expensive according to nasa so why
waste it on new outfits if you could
just wash the ones you've got
when you figure an astronaut needs 150
pounds of clothes in space
per year that adds up quick especially
on a three-year mars mission
in its initial experiment procter gamble
says it will send up detergent custom
made for space in december so scientists
can see how the enzymes and other
ingredients
react to six months of weightlessness
and then next may stain removal pens and
wipes will be delivered for testing by
astronauts
procter and gamble is developing a
washer and dryer combo that could
operate on the moon
or even mars using minimal amounts of
water and detergent
a machine like that could also prove
useful here on earth too
so here's to that time-honored earth
tradition of laundry day
soon coming to an international space
station near you tanya j
powers fox news
[Music]
it's time for your fox news commentary
joe koncha
what's on your mind the washington post
urges americans to set up
white accountability groups no really
well it's official
the post which used to be one of the
most respected publications on the
planet
has gone full activism it is actually
asking white people
to create whites only quote
accountability groups
unquote and meet regularly and
indefinitely like this is alcoholics
anonymous
while forcing themselves into a quote
period of deep shame
unquote over their race so wait this is
supposed to improve race relations
because at last check the greatest
leader of the civil rights movement
believe his name was martin luther king
jr
once said we should not judge people by
the color of their skin
but by the content of their character
but at the washington post in 2021
they're telling us to do the exact
opposite in categorizing people
by the color of their skin which is
literally the definition of racism
congratulations wapo you just succeeded
in dividing the country even further
while turning your paper into a laughing
stock democracy dies in darkness indeed
i'm joe conscious
you've been listening to the fox news
rundown stay up to date by subscribing
to this podcast at foxnewspodcasts.com
and for up to the minute news go to
foxnews.com
[Music]
from the fox news podcasts network i'm
ben dominic publisher of the federalists
and i'm inviting you to join a new
conversation with the smartest thinkers
out there about the country and where
we're going
subscribe to the ben dominic podcast
subscribe and listen now by going to
foxnewspodcasts.com